I I wasted my click muscles for this you
know [ __ ] kid it's like these people
that use conservative so-called
conservative sites are resorting to the
same stuff is as M night Shyamalan the
trailer he should just compile his
trailers and sell that movie theater but
his movie suck very glad to have this
next guest sorry I'm all nasally all of
a sudden my allergies flared up but I've
known him for a long time and as a
matter of fact outside of Andrew
Breitbart I probably owe more of my
career or what little there is of it to
this man I'll explain as we get into it
first right off the bat you can find him
at Alfonzo Rachel calm he does videos
commentary music so thanks for being on
man thank you in terms of what little of
your career you have yeah I would
probably it fall for that I'll take
credit for that and I'll just really
yeah exactly
it started off well and then it went off
the rails really quickly no I remember
you know so you know that guy you knows
oh no it's more so the other way around
you were the one who vouched for me it's
funny I get a lot of tweets and people
say well why don't you ever go you know
in PJTV or have you thought of
collaborating with so I did in 2009 we
did this video which looking back now is
almost prophetic called everyday
Republicans and it was just every sort
of stereotype and that's been the play
book about against Republicans now right
racist sexist homophobic this was before
occupy well actually you know it will
get it up for those who are listening to
rest early on a lot of with credit calm
we'll get a video linked up but you were
at PJTV
and you know it was really impactful cuz
you were actually a big reason for me
from transitioning from stand-up to
online because I saw your rants and I
thought hey this guy's doing it and he's
doing really well
and he's you know resonating hey I don't
necessarily just need to do a club
anymore I can use this YouTube right and
you rat PJTV and they started kind of
asking you the sketch stuff comedy stuff
and you being incredibly humble because
you could have done it said hey you know
what I'm probably not your best guy but
you might want to talk to this Steven
guy you know you didn't even know me and
you put my name in the mix and that's
where it all got started I don't even
know if you remember that I do it even
to this day you know they asked me to do
things say why don't
you don't want me for that I look good I
know my wheelhouse there's certain
things where it's like let man I can do
this I don't want to do that it's not
just because of me it's like look I'm
trying to protect your things you don't
want me to mess up your theme it's just
let me do what I'm good at you know
right well you've done some funny
sketches though I mean when we had you
in the the Peace Prize video you stole a
video with just a look oh yeah you know
just being a black guy gets a Peace
Prize and you're looking at me and I was
like oh man so as prices get more of him
in there so it's been it's been a long
time and a lot of people don't realize
kind of that's that's where I started
more so in the conservative movement and
then Andrew Breitbart picked me up and
we were kind of all in that same circle
of friends for a while until he passed
so you do a lot of videos right here's
my question to you because you don't get
to talk about this a lot kind of like I
don't really get to talk about my
background so much as a Canadian what
people are asking you know what's your
background how does obviously a man a
man of color I believe is the correct
term now become a conservative activist
really make a living off of it what was
the transition for you oh well you know
the first step is I'm a musician right
and uh you know in me playing in
different bands you know musicians tend
to lean to the left and you know just
there's something about it that just
wasn't because I wasn't you know I was a
default liberal right no I was a default
you know Democrat and but you know the
more I started to listen you know to the
narrative and the things that they would
say about themselves you know how they
would lock themselves as being tolerant
accepting and open-minded all that sort
of stuff and then I would hear the
opinions that they would have on you
know Christians conservatives
Republicans and I say there's nothing
about what you have to say that sounds
tolerant or accept or anything like that
so what I started to question the
narrative that's what I started to see
that belligerence really come out and I
was like look man one thing I've always
known is that entertainment is a very
powerful way to move a message so I want
to use my music to promote this message
so what I would write up songs and
lyrics suggests and stuff like that oh
man I would get chewed out so I was like
I know what there has to be a way where
I can get this message out there so I
was teaching martial arts now when did
this happen like around what age oh this
is a Late Late Night just just before
2000 rolled around I started to see it
and then uh but it started to grind on
my nerves I mean embarrassingly it's
a long time before I said okay I need to
I need to see what part I can do and so
like you know century turns over 911
happens around 2007 I said alright man I
got to do something so I I had my
martial arts to do and when I would
close up shop for the night I would set
up a camera and I would just start
recording what was on my mind and I
started uploading those videos up on
MySpace got a little bit of a following
on my space my space oh yes this is you
know a little flashback for you there
somebody said once you put that stuff up
on YouTube man so I did this skit I said
oh wow YouTube man I could make like
videos like that I saw sigh I had never
heard of YouTube you know this how under
a rock I am right I saw some stuff that
people do on YouTube say heck yeah I'm
out try some of that stuff and that's
when I made that video of the boat
reapers like my little Star Wars parody
right and I did a you know my bid on
Sarah Palin and uh you know that got
that wouldn't viral it I think that's
when I caught the attention of like Gary
Sinise and Breitbart and Bill Whittle
and a name I think they just gotta toss
around say hey he might be good for a PJ
TV and that's how I ended up on there
right like yeah that we and then
everyone knows the story from there you
know my interest was in kind of what
happened before that because it's one of
those things where people just don't it
was one of those things was the right
person at the right time not that you're
not telling you're obviously talented
that's why you've made it a consistent
living and you've stayed on the radar
and you still have viral videos it was
one of those things where you know young
black men didn't say those things you
know what's crazy
and you can correct me if I'm wrong here
I feel like we got to the point where
more people were saying what you were
saying it was at least okay it was at
least getting a little more acceptable
and now in 2015 the racial divide is
worse than ever in my lifetime born in
87 I feel like it's gotten worse as bad
as humanly possible in the last couple
years I mean when I was growing up right
Rodney King was a huge issue that was a
huge thing we've had four riots in the
last year you know the terrible just
really quick I tell you what are reasons
why I tell that story man is because
when it comes down to it me being at
PJTV and this thing's that culminates
soon is we're talking
about you know the dynamic that it has
and how I got there how people perceive
it well it might if those was just like
what you're talking about miss racial
divide where I'm at isn't because of
what I believe I'm only where I am
because I get paid for it that is the
perception of why I am where I am right
that's like there's it's like you keep
if you have an opposing worldview this
is how full of themselves that liberals
and Afrocentric think they are with
their worldview they think their
worldview is so solid and here so
fooling themselves that if you think
apart from them then there has to be a
nefarious reason for it rebel excluded
because I'm getting paid right let me
assure you before I was ever paid for it
I was already getting cussed out for it
I was already being alienated for it I
was hard you know separated and and
chastised for what it was that I was
believing I wouldn't get it done hey hey
big oil big oil Koch brothers Big Pharma
don't deny it
that's the youtube comment section guys
like Big Oil pays me because I do did
Big Oil was paying me don't you think
I'd have a budget to have better videos
when you started there off they look
nice now yeah it's one thing to for me
I'm like the big thing is I say if
States want to legalize weed fine but on
a personal level I don't think it's good
for you that's my stance right and
that's considered a radical stance to
the super pro marijuana Lobby and then
it's like well he's just been paid by
big pharma
I'm gonna why would Big Pharma pay me
with the YouTube channel and uh you know
a syndicated radio show why they have so
much influence why would they do it and
people don't even think it through again
it's that social engineering like a lot
of the time there are issues where I
think the right they get it wrong for
example like this issue right now in
Kentucky the woman who won't issue a
same-sex marriage license there are a
lot of issues to get into there she is
working for the government at that point
and that is the law so I do understand
people saying okay either go work
somewhere else or do it because that's
your job just like if you work at GM you
have to be a part of the UAW whether you
want to or not but then they change the
contract honor so I understand both
sides the issue to me that matters and I
feel the right should focus on is what
you just touched is the social
engineering it's the same thing with
feminism it's the same thing with being
pro Islam it's the same thing with
racism with
sexism it's you have to think this way
or you have to be banned from public
discussion and that's constant through
everything and that's always something
you've hit on and I feel like a lot of
other conservatives miss those
opportunities sure you know and if I can
like you know touch on you know a little
bit of each aspect that you said like
even with with medical marijuana man
medical here's the thing with medical
marijuana for me number one if marijuana
didn't keep people high they wouldn't
care about it they're only using people
suffering with with what certain
ailments they're only using them to
promote the idea of getting marijuana
legal so they can enjoy it for
recreational purposes they do not care
about people who are sick first up to
I'm not into legalizing dependency you
know we got we already got a problem
with legalizing dependency you know
whether it's the welfare state people
mean Ward's of the state and stuff like
that much you want to put something on
the scene to make that legal - I love
Tony Bennett you know saying we should
make marijuana legal and let the doctors
be in control of it you know make sure
that the doctors regulate how it's gonna
be controlled that way we do away with
the black markets like okay okay when
the doctor tells you that you can't have
any more of your drugs because he thinks
that you're having too much what do you
think that patients gonna do he's gonna
go to the black market so he can get
some more I don't think this stuff well
it's also the big thing to his drug
dealers are not drug dealers they're
criminals who make money off of drugs
they'll find a way to make money off of
something else I kind of go back my
issue with it is the lies surrounding it
you know people say well you the reason
the medical industry is against is
because you can't patent a plant it's
not true there are many drugs taken from
marijuana compounds that are patented
they just don't work that well the only
one that does work well is one that
comes from gosh I don't know the
compound we can bring it up but it helps
with nausea for cancer doesn't really
get you high though so people are
pushing for that drug exactly it's like
it is legal and they did patent it do
you know the most popular drug one of
the most popular prescriptions in
America you notice it's retin-a retinol
you want retinol this vitamin a it helps
keep your skin from getting wrinkly if
they can patent vitamin A they can
patent anything in marijuana so if
someone wants to puff up on their own in
their own house it's one of those issues
that's where a more libertarian but my
issue is the lie that will the big
farmers are good because they can't
patent it if it worked
they'd be the first ones they've tried
to be the first ones to make a ton of
money off of it just like the supplement
industry if you look at the top five
biggest supplement companies they're all
owned by Big Pharma they make this
trouble think forward to what you use to
vitamins they own companies so anyway
sir we got nothing a rabbit room but
yeah you're right but all that stuff
because it comes down to that social
engineering because people are being
inundated with these ideas there is it
man as soon as they hit this the school
campus then matter what grade level all
practically doesn't matter what grade
level you're in they're already being
socially engineered for it it's it
starts like you know what when you turn
on your television set it starts when
you turn on your radio it starts when
you look on the internet it's everywhere
men just this idea these self-righteous
self-serving ideas that are constantly
being promoted and they affect
everything race relations marijuana
sexual orientation uh you know
entitlements everything then it's just
all this self-serving self-righteous
propaganda that people think will make
the world better and it's like it
doesn't work and I tell you what loading
us if we're just talking honestly I've
talked about this with my peanut
producer Jared I mean we're both you
know brothers as Christians we've talked
about this a long time
my producer Jared is too but lately
because of everything that's been
happening we've said you know what we
really have to guard our hearts because
of what the media is putting out it does
actually cause me to think in a way that
generalizes sometimes negatively and I
hate it but when you see the protests
and when you see today again cops being
attacked cops being refused service at
Arby's and may see a holy crap like how
did everything get so bad so quickly and
the media immediately goes it's because
of white oppression you can only be told
that you're you know that you're
privileged for so long and that you
don't deserve anything you've earned for
so long until people want to fight to
protect it it's not that their
identities and their whiteness their
identities and their accomplishments and
they're being told no you don't have any
accomplishments it's just because you're
white and it's created more racism and I
think everyone has to guard their heart
against it absolutely and you know just
like you said man when we have will be
speaking of the the Christian element
man I'm load I'm noticing that you know
the more people want to bring more money
in like especially when it comes to like
education or whatever is that they want
funny they want more
coming in and at the same time they want
more God coming out and they really
think that this is the fix for all
things like no it doesn't mean while
stigmatizing money you know the wrath of
the one percenter in it it's like okay
you think money is a problem but yet you
think it's gonna solve your problems it
doesn't work that way there's a reason
why in god we trust' us on our money
because we're supposed to know that your
security is not in your money the
stability of your nation the stability
of the state of mankind is not in your
money it's in God but you guys want to
bring in more money shove God out you're
doing it totally backwards you need to
bring more God in and then let the money
God let God take care of the money
nothing we don't need to get rid of
money if money was evil God wouldn't
accept it on that note we have to keep
the lights on with these advertisers Oh
fons up Rachel we'll be right back we
are back as we kept the lights on with
the evil money coming from our sponsors
it's which is always talked about right
before we went there yeah you know it's
one of those things and it's uh menhir
x' the thing leftists don't believe that
they believe money is bad unless it's in
the hand of the government for some
reason all of a sudden money which is
really just an amplifier of character is
inherently used in an altruistic way if
it's in the hands of a centralized power
and it's an irony that I think is lost
on the left and I think it's an irony
that's particularly been portrayed on
the black American public that there
you've talked about this a lot there are
the benevolent sort of dictators they're
there to help you and you've talked
about this too a lot you just did a
video recently that went incredibly
viral with Michelle Obama and you said
something you know but hey you're gonna
get you're gonna get your your
government help but not if you have a
working father in the house that's
something you've talked about a lot do
you think for those who aren't aware
tell them of how the welfare laws affect
the black community and how Democrats
deliberately use it as a marketing tool
cuz a lot of people don't even know oh
man it comes at you know from so many
angles you know and the funny thing
about it is that you know we have this
generation of feminists you know who
want to come off as like they're strong
and they're independent and hey you
could raise that kid on your own and
you're a strong especially you does it
even with the black community I hate
with you know we have black when it's
I'm a strong black woman you're a strong
black woman now if a white woman was to
come out there say I'm a strong white
one
we call her racist you know but you know
but the point I know he's married to a
white woman that's okay for me to say
that right I know I know one of those
racist Republican conservative white
women is like oh oh but she happens to
be married to me and she's very pretty
and she's very sweet and every time I've
met her you know I'm going race has
nothing to do with it you just hit the
jackpot
good for you yeah I know right you know
these ideals that people put into their
heads you know and then these would be
same women who think that they're strong
and independent go and turn to the
government to assist them right wait a
minute what happened to all that
strengthen and independence but the
government has become the subject come
on even that's one of those things like
I get I understand that there are white
Americans who are out of touch with
black culture okay get it but that was
just absurd and hilarious but because
the state has become the supplement for
the Father you know you got the break of
the family right got you got you know
more than more than 50% of people just
falling out of wedlock you know there's
this it's like they want the economy to
get better how do you you know the
economy is symptomatic it's not our core
problem right you know the economy is is
is a reflection of the in the unstable
economy is a reflection of an unstable
culture we got unstable marriages we got
kids grown up in owns unstable homes we
just got unstable relationships between
people
unstable business relationships and
people expect to have economy that's
gonna be a part or or a the opposite of
that no it's not gonna work that way
right so you know but these are things
that people deal with it's not exclusive
to the black community but in the but
for some reason the black community is
making the most noise about it but isn't
doing the things that's gonna bring the
problem to a halt yeah
it's it's a tough place to be because
and you know you hate to even be like
well because you're black the fact is
you can talk about it as far as me being
able to reach people in the black
community it's it's it's not impossible
because of the narrative that's been
said it requires someone like you it
sucks but those identity politics sort
of play a role in who from the
conservative side could even even have a
voice to reach them
we tell you what there's a lot of truth
to that but at the same time you know
they hate me more than they hate you
yeah it's like there's there's this kind
of notion that because I'm black you
know I can I I have the Liberty to to to
express these ideas no I don't because
once I have these ideas I don't qualify
as black anymore you know I'm saying we
add Hughley on the show and that's what
he said you know not one of them would
be respecting the black community I said
well what about Alfonzo Rachel what
about Larry elder what about Colin
Powell
what about Condoleezza Rice he goes now
one of them would be respected in the
black community if they walked into a
neighborhood I'm gone well but those are
respectable people thank you thank you a
hey you're so right but think I
appreciate the compliment is being a
respectful person but you know but it's
difficult I don't look at you and think
at prec amount of disrespect and he
doesn't deserve my respect like why why
is it a justification it well they
wouldn't respect them well then those
people are bad people these people
desert they've earned respect through
the way they lived their lives and their
accomplishments they've actually earned
a voice and I was amazed but he just
thought that was such a sound argument
well it is said because they do think
it's sorry and the thing is it's not
impossible it's difficult but it's not
impossible there's ways to get in there
it takes a lot of finessing right that's
a that's one of the things that too many
conservatives lat is finesse you know if
you want to deliberately see to take
style it takes you know it takes style
guts it takes some finesse you know in
into it plus it takes it does take a
little bit of money you know which
conservatives always seem to have a you
know they got money when it comes to
like you know funding these super PACs
and whatever but in terms to you know
finding the actual cultural effort you
know they want political representation
I'm trying to tell you that's not going
to be stable unless you have stable
cultural representation so you don't
need to learn how to feed that but you
know these things man they have to be
taken into the culture and there has to
be a method upon which you know to do it
and that's just as bad you know people I
mean listen you tell my guys like you
know Gary or Andrew and people who were
friends with michelle malkin you know
they have obviously disrespectfully
because they work in that realm and I
always felt immense respect from all of
those people I mean you know Gary Sinise
every now and then he's not by the way
for those listen he's not a political
guy he just a very helps the troops and
he wrecking
as people who do that and who are out
there who are supporting America and
just always this respect that I feel I
hadn't earned in the face of someone
that great
whereas with Republican politicians
you're in the room and it's always kind
of like oh yeah what you do is important
too that's cute you know I mean don't
you get that just me it's just me cuz
I'm a court jester maybe it's just me
it's like who the hell are you I mean
you know the only reason anyone listens
to what you have to say is because you
have millions of dollars from a PAC
nobody cares about you you're running
for president to increase your speaking
fees a lot of the time it really is a
problem there is a problem and I've have
to be you know I speak out as much right
now toward the right as I do toward the
left I feel like it's gotten to a point
where it's our responsibility because we
can't just accept the entire thing as it
is because it's better than the Hillary
Clinton are better than Bernie Sanders
we need to elevate it you know the
movement needs to be elevated right now
and I think we're being honest it's it's
in a place that really needs some help
indeed it's tough love tough love yeah
you know sometimes you gotta you you
know you got to dig in a little bit and
you know and you know and keep it real
and keep it real okay you know what
speaking of keeping it real this is
going to end our terrestrial broadcast
here I want you to stay for a couple
minutes just for the the webcast where
you can go all crazy profane because we
know you are louder with Crowder go to
the site if you're listening on radio to
hear an extended web version stay tuned
for this we're on the web extended
edition you know it's funny you talked
about that listen I was just talking
about this today I would not have been
able to get started in the movement I
just started doing these videos as a
stand-up comic did videos people like
Michelle Malkin Andrew Breitbart had no
reason to support me but they did I got
a message yesterday from one of the top
conservative sites asking if I would pay
them to embed my video and I'm going you
make all the revenue anyways it's your
own post it's on your website I'm like
no I can't and I don't make enough
revenue you know embed advertising is
not nearly as high as a website because
you can't have as many ads it seems that
original content and voices like yours
in many cases now our giving way to
clickbait to plagiarism to like for some
reason street fights I don't know if
you've seen this are being posted on
conservative sites there's been a
yeah literally like street fights
there's been a noticeable shift where I
haven't seen a new though you know
really since you and there haven't been
many people kind of doing what I'm doing
in recent years because it just isn't
profitable it's not sustainable have you
noticed that shift oh sorry you lost
your headphones there yeah sure oh you
can see me
I could see yes what do you think I
can't see you well I can't see you
that's not beer you yeah you can see me
well I can yeah but it's just a picture
of you know you should be able to see
I'm sending you video Wow
no man I just been sitting here like no
picture
are you having like a webcam up to your
Super Nintendo what are you doing okay
there we go
all right have you noticed though that
shift I have okay I have noticed it's
like it's almost like dude it's they
promote their website almost like
tabloids you know I can go into the
grocery store and I can see stuff like
this but I'm looking on tabloids you
know such and such and then click here
to see the answer did such-and-such do
this and like manner are we go in there
are we going the shallow route you know
I know what we are we are the biggest we
look at the biggest conservative size
right now that's what they do and it's
funny we got accused of quick baby that
they were was like cop refused at Arby's
for being a police officer mmm and we
were like click here to find out more it
was like that's like you knew yeah it
was in the title like you want someone
to click or something prom with getting
someone to hear a story I mean the same
thing if you would do with your videos
but yeah things worse like Donald Trump
lays epic smackdown that may blow the
lid off Hillary Clinton's campaign and
he got it and he's just like I don't
like Hillary Clinton and that's it it's
like yeah it's like I I wasted my click
muscles this you know [ __ ] kid it's
like these people that use conservative
so-called conservative sites are
resorting to the same stuff this as M
night Shyamalan the trailer he should
just compile his trailers and sell that
and movie theater but his movie suck I
can't believe he suckered me again you
suckered me again ago see here one of
your crappy movies with your awesome
trailers I know well I think a lot signs
was okay until the end and then
everything since then has been complete
crap yeah was good I like
does before Mel Gibson went a little
crazy this is one of the funniest tapes
ever yeah so you know it is one of those
things I hope I'm always glad when I see
you around cuz you know I I keep a keep
tabs and on the big boys and why are you
posting this and then every now and then
you know see one of your things pop up
and I'll go okay some good stuff is
still getting through but yeah man it's
it's it's really really changed and I'll
tell you I mean I was just a comic and
an actor and I got into this because of
people like you Andrew it was namely you
Andrew Michelle and then Garry those
were the people who changed it for me um
I don't think I get into it now if I
were if I were you know a 21 year old
kid today and I looked at it I don't
think I don't think I'd get into it I
think it would be too toxic
I hate and we need that comedy that's
what you know that's why we need you out
there and you know and for like me a lot
of people hey you're that comedian right
like oh no I'm not a comedian I would
tell people steven crowder is a comedian
I'm not a comedian I try to make my
videos fun and funny I'm not I don't
think I'm like I'm not an actual joke
writer know that what people yeah it's
like you know I got a funny delivery
that's great I can't write a joke to
save my life but if you guys want comedy
you know talk to people like Stephen cuz
it's so needed it is the medicine that
really helps to I mean it's the flavor
that really helps the medicine go down
I'm a musician
that's what I do 20-pound sledge that's
my thing I see it right now in the
background yeah that's right you know
hit me in the back of the head
everything you know comedy man people
need that comedy cuz you know just like
when you said that you're a jester who
did the king of the court listen to
who's the one who had the liberty to
just go ahead and speak his mind and and
and entertain the court it was the
Jester yeah ends up in stocks with
tomatoes so that's we know how this
story but it's funny you say that the
people come to you and say that because
people come up to me and go hey you're
that black guy with the rants and I go
no no no no no no you're thinking of
Alfonso Rachel so we both get confused
reach other last question before we go
because I know you have to actually go
to PJTV and record it which people
should be watching why don't you age
you're like Rob Lowe
I've grown the beard to hide my wrinkles
man no I don't believe that I don't
believe that you don't age literally
since 2000 was a 2009 we're both a PJ I
think so what 2015 yeah you look the
same
well thank you how does that happen what
are you doing what kind of drugs are you
doing it's honestly a hey let me get
spiritual on you a second the Lord
preserves people until they fulfill
their purpose that's the only thing I
could think of man cuz you know as I'm I
jump food you know the only workout I
get is playing on my drums and I
practice martial arts and stuff like
that but you know really unless you know
if the Lord's got some free to do
he'll keep you preserved man you know
you'll age and stuff like that but he'll
unless they spread out across my body is
just a broken-down piece of meat right
now got so many injuries but that's what
happens with that happen is Brazilian
jiu-jitsu we talk about the martial arts
it's like it has a 100% injury rate so
you just have to kind of accept it as
you move along the trails like
everything look at your videos and I
feel wrong but I get angry because you
still look the same
I'm like oh how does he do it a
cryogenic freezer alright so thank you
so much where's the best place for
people to find you
Rachele dot-com thanks man you know
Alfonso breeze calm and 20-pound sledge
calm absolutely and you really do go
check it out specifically you know
videos if you're into is it would you
call it metal 20-pound sledge well I
don't want to miss rim it's hard rock
it's hard rock like the like the like
the restaurant you go down 20-pound
sledge you pick up a couple of feet is
you get to see the Judge Dredd uniform
fun zone Rachel thanks so much for for
coming in we really do appreciate it
before I tell you subscribe by clicking
my face or one of these videos next to
me I want to take this opportunity to
tell you about something very important
plaguing our country gangs of violent
hermaphrodites plaguing our cities
picking on the innocent and those less
fortunate than them if you see them be
sure to alert the proper authorities